okay if you play cs go if you watch cs
go if you care about cs go if you've
ever even heard of cs go
then christmas might have just come
early because valve have given us a new
operation
but this time it's not just a bunch of
new skins and some maps you'll probably
never play
this time it could be a game changer
[Music]
okay i am literally dying to tell you
about this operation but before i do i
have to tell you about the score esports
awards
2020 yes covert or no covid pandemic or
no pandemic
we are recognizing the best that esports
had to offer
in this crazy asterisk of a year it's
going down december 11th
live on youtube and twitch and i want
you to be there
okay back to cs go and holy [ __ ] where
do we even start
well the new operation is called broken
fang it's going to cost you 15 bucks
american
or about 13 euro it's got new and deeper
stat tracking features for you
it's got quality of life matchmaking
upgrades that mimic services like faceit
and it's got all the new maps skins and
cosmetics that you'd expect
from a new operation now granted we did
not get 128 tick servers
nor did we get a legitimate kernel level
anti-cheat that isn't completely
half-assed
but even so honestly i think this
operation is just
now before we get into anything else
there is one elephant in the room when
it comes to this operation that we have
to talk about first
and that's this pings you can now ping
an
area or an object like say a gun or the
bomb that's in front of you
it'll be visible to your teammates and
appear on the mini-map and
honestly it is a massive upgrade in
terms of split-second communication
with your team let's say you're playing
a map and you don't know the
hyper-specific call-out of where you are
and you need to communicate
instantly with your teammates just ping
it let's say you see the bomb going down
and you want to let your team know
exactly where it's planted before all
those smokes bloom
ping it you see an op in the dying
seconds of the round you want picked up
just ping it this seems to be the single
new feature that everyone is talking
about
and it's certainly got the pros excited
now if you buy the new operation you get
access to what's called broken fang
premier matchmaking
and if you guys play mm you're going to
want to check this out because this is
where some of the best new features live
in the new update welcome to premiere
mode voting is about to begin
waiting for a pilot as soon as your
broken fang premiere matchmaking queue
pops
you'll be ushered into a pick band lobby
where the two teams will select
what map gets played and what side you
want to start once the map starts the
traditional free-for-all warm-up is
replaced with a kind of 1v1 aimed duel
with a random member of the enemy team
now this might sound like a small thing
but honestly using the warm up to
actually warm up instead of getting
camped by auto snipers
or spammed with a negev and spawned by
your own teammates
is an improvement i like throughout your
game you're going to notice a few things
are different
for example press tab and you're going
to see that different stats than you're
used to
are displayed including for the first
time headshot percentage
also after every round you'll notice
this graph pops up that charts a stack
called
win chance and it goes up or down
depending on
what happened in the previous round i'm
not 100
sure why this is useful yet but it's
cool then of course there's the ping
which we already talked about
and the chat wheel now forget the old
bot commands because the chat wheel is a
fully customizable feature
that gives you a much deeper range of
pre-recorded communication messages
this feature along with the ping is
going to be incredible for improving
communication among
your team especially for those people
who don't have a mic who don't want to
press push to talk in a firefight
or who just don't speak your language
the chat wheels so deep there's even an
option to ask your teammates for a decoy
if you
feel like trolling i guess as you'd
expect from a new operation you can earn
points or stars by completing
certain objectives and spend them on
broken fang rewards
which we will get to in just a moment
now before you spend that cash
you can go to the broken fang advanced
stats page which has stuff like
heat maps and charts that display weapon
performance or map
win rate and this is something you'd
previously have to go to a third party
for
so it's a pretty neat feature we've also
got seven yes
seven new maps and a retake mode
which is big with the retake mode with
the pick band system and some of the
other features they've implemented in
broken fang
it seems pretty clear that valve is
taking a page out of third-party
matchmaking services like
esea and faceit's book question is are
valve testing some of these features in
the broken fang premiere matchmaking
service
to eventually roll them into regular mm
you got to believe that they didn't
spend all this time creating
all of these quality of life upgrades
just to delete them after the operation
ends so i would expect to see them in
the base game
in 16 weeks and then there's the
cosmetics
now i have a thought or two on some of
the agent skins in particular
but there's one guy i knew would have an
opinion about absolutely everything
and that is the score esports resident
skin fiend dimitri pascaluda
alright so as the score esports is one
and only cosmetic
degenerate i am here to walk you through
the only thing in this operation that
actually matters aside from that ping
that ping is genuinely life-changing
i'm talking of course about schemes
so let's get right to it there is as
expected a new case
and the offerings aren't too shabby but
what really matters
are the yellows last year we were
blessed with four new knives
this year we finally got new gloves
now personally i'm a sport glove guy and
while i don't hate the new designs
it doesn't seem like any of them have
what it takes to take on pandora's
as the goat that said the motos
slap especially blood pressure and
literally
every one of the specialist gloves are
fire
the recoil stickers and graffiti they
added are
actually really cool not to mention
creative but
let's be honest the broken fang stickers
aren't anything to write home about
they've also introduced skill group
patches so silvers like colin can flex
how scrubby they are
and a whole new set of agents as well as
a few old ones
all of whom seem great anyway
all of this is lovely but it's not going
to make you any money so let's talk
about the only thing that
actually matters operation skins
so just like with last year's operation
shattered web
broken fangs saw valve bless us with
three
brand spanking new collections control
havoc and ancient needless to say
each boasts an ultra rare covert skin
that will be
extremely sought after for havoc it's
the x-ray ak-47 which
i'll be honest isn't for me for ancient
it's this badass red snake skin for the
m4a1s
which definitely slaps and for control
which seems like the sickest of the
three
i mean it has a sapphire a1s for
sake why does this utterly useless
weapon get
blessed with the best skins it's a
travesty
anyway it's safe to say that the crown
jewel of the control collection
is also that of the entire operation the
op
fade everyone is drooling over this
thing including some of the
flyest wrist flickers of all time
personally
look i'm gonna say it i was a little
disappointed but
to be fair i've never been a huge fan of
fade in general so it's completely
understandable that i wouldn't go
gaga over them slapping it on and off
that is just my personal preference
though and it changes
nothing about the fact that this is bar
none the hottest
and most egregiously expensive skin you
can pull from broken fang
if there's one thing you want gaben to
bless you with during this operation
it's the op fade anyway that's pretty
much it the last thing i'll say about
these collections
might actually be the most important
though which is just that they're
well new for those who don't know
valve spent years re-releasing old
collections
whenever a new operation came around to
the point that it became
more or less expected with shattered web
valve
bucked that trend releasing three
completely new collections
the fact that they've done that again
with broken fang suggests that
maybe valve are done reintroducing old
collections
at least for now so why does that matter
because it means that some
already exorbitant price tags could get
even
crazier remember some of the most
sought-after skins in the whole of cs go
are operation skins
the prince wild lotus gungner and yes
the dragonlore if the collections of
which these skins are apart
are never reintroduced it could be huge
stonks for whoever's lucky enough to own
them
okay i don't know about you guys but
after hearing that i kind of want to
wrap this up
go by a thousand stars and pray for that
fade but right before we do i have a few
thoughts of my own on the cosmetics
and look i know it's not enough fade
it's not a huge deal but i did
appreciate
the agent patches that they gave us in
this operation
you can display a skill matchmaking
group in an homage to famous heavy metal
bands
and i'm thinking i might need to pick up
some silver slayers
now as far as the agent skins go i think
they're fine it's interesting that valve
decided to go
more wacky for these ones than they did
with shattered web
i mean just look at these guys you got a
guy who looks like the main character of
gta vice city with a hockey mask on
then you got the joker ripoff and of
course
condom guy we just have to hope that
this time around
valve gave some thought to the
visibility of these agents on various
maps
because we all know how that turned out
last time okay but jokes aside
this operation has been a blast so far
valve has given us desperately needed
improvements to the matchmaking system
they've given us much deeper
communication tools to bring the game in
line with
other fps titles in 2020 and of course
plenty of cosmetic goodies that you
would expect
now none of that's a real anti-cheat but
it's pretty good
okay so valve released obviously a bunch
of new agent skins and as with shattered
web they came with extremely cringy bios
obviously purposely cringy the worst
part is though each one has
flavor text like a tag line that defines
them
they're unreal for example first
lieutenant farlow
actually first lieutenant farlow
canadian
what are they doing over there drinking
milkshakes
what this this is another swamp member
john van helen
cask is that like a van halen joke his
tagline is
i can bring you back to life but i can't
make you live
holy [ __ ] did they find that on deviant
art in 2003
i need dimitri for this one this guy has
a latin bio
uh his tagline is tacita
said more to ferum
what does that mean you know it means
silent but deadly
silent but deadly okay so he's a fart
okay okay final one
gateway sally her tagline is
now you don't see me and now you still
don't
what the [ __ ] this is some [ __ ] you
would find on tumblr a 14 year old
rothies